el hombre fuerte de belarús alexander
lukashenko prometió una nueva
constitución para el país durante una
asamblea popular con representantes
leales a su partido el líder bielorruso
hizo alarde de las próximas reformas en
la carta magna- demandadas desde hace
meses por la oposición que podrían estar
listas para someterse a referendo a
principios de 2022
tres personas pongamos mucho
distribuiremos radicalmente los poderes
prepararemos la tercera versión de la
constitución el proyecto de constitución
estará listo durante este año se
debatirá a nivel nacional este año el
mandatario también se jactó de
sobrevivir a una guerra relámpago
extranjera en un desafiante discurso
conocido como el último dictador de
europa enfrentó desde agosto de 2020 las
manifestaciones más multitudinarias
desde que llegó al poder en 1994 miles
de personas tomaron las calles del país
para exigir su renuncia después de haber
afirmado haber ganado los comicios del
año pasado que según los opositores
fueron fraudulentos las marchas fueron
reprimidas con violencia dejando decenas
de muertos cientos de arrestados y la
principal líder de la oposición
déjanos acá ya se encuentra en el exilio
actualmente hay 246 presos políticos en
belarús el número de personas reprimidas
solo está creciendo lukashenko prometió
en noviembre cambiar la constitución
para calmar las protestas que en los
últimos meses han perdido fuerza debido
a las persecuciones por parte de las
autoridades pero tanto analistas como la
oposición tienen pocas expectativas de
que los cambios anunciados produzcan
resultados tangibles y democráticos
consideran una farsa para ayudarle a
perpetuarse en el poder pese a perder el
apoyo ciudadano